l a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti che sono
video sono famigerati succhiasse glory
plasma con un menù più romantico del
solito e che è fantastico per questo
gioco visto considerato che un gioco un
po del cazzo tracce comunità l'ultima
volta che l'ho fatto aveva fatto
presente che quasi tutti i livelli che
c'erano qua
tranne walt clyde e easy peasy questo
onore dico surreal power
l'obiettivo è sempre quello di arrivare
alla fine alla fine ci stiamo solo fare
dobbiamo completarlo nel minor tempo
possibile
li ho più tutto a posto perfetto cosa
può o non ci voglio credere ma che sfiga
di merda
l'ultimo secondo sono ma va a cagare ma
da easy peasy una sega perfetto vai
ottima tattica per schivare le palle
comunque complimenti
dovresti giocare ad oggi con nel tempo
libero
bravo ma un millimetro video di rotture
piazza ragazzo con una comica sorridendo
la misura non lo sto facendo apposta e
penso se lo facessi apposta piano piano
occhio occhio perfetto succhiami
ginocchio destro perfetto sapevo che
potevi farcela ero socio hanno
migliorato di italiano tempo a ragazzi
l'altra gola era walk line che sarebbe
arrampicato sul muro con degli anni
family va bene ma tra l'altro devo alla
madonna
e vabbè ce l'ho fatta mica veramente
ma che figata è mica se si incastra la
china era geniale attimo dopo voglio
provare a rifare
ho vinto posso parlare di farlo
incastrando la macchina del buco da ci
provo devo cadere il dritto però un
macello perciò posso fare la lega me lo
sento
by ok tensio cam
come no la madonna che è successo lì a
posto tutte guidi e qualche a ma non si
può ed è qui che infatti è rientrato non
era possibile ha semplicemente perché
non entra nei buchi è che vuoi rifarlo
starà solo la madonna e la macchina di
batman questa anzi di spider man che
figata riesco a frenare sui muri com'è
possibile
ecco mi sa che stavolta non riesco a
frenare più però è stato figo finché è
durato piu of pain il cubo del dolore se
non riuscite un frate facciamo non lo so
janet imi pronto pronto fiscaletti dark
[ __ ] sapevo che cade volo vorrei
rifare il peace che letto dark tribù fu
tv fu siete maledetti ho preso c'è poi
anche senza volerlo perfetto
non so se me lo merito troppo sto
checkpoint maasai con maxi [ __ ]
forte non ho toccato nulla ma la sua
gara niente perché muore europea ma
tumore esattamente muori per quale
motivo che non capisco perfetto senza
una gamba senza una donna ok ok ok ok
che aveva fatto dove governi facendo
dovrei andare però va bene lasciamo bene
vai piano zio e il piano che tanto non
riesce a far nulla se vai veloce nato
non serve andare veloci perfetto piano
piano sono fatti problemi
mica che stoffa è no non puoi cadere
adesso quando freno così bene mi salvo
la vita non puoi morire così ci hai
fatto l'ha provata almeno rimane vivo
cosa ti stai cimentando in nuovi tipi di
tuffi dai dai dai dai
era tanto difficile cioè non ho capito
devo un carmelo ancora fatto è perché
devo ancora beccare 50 lancione che
questo ok adesso l'ho fatto ma perché se
morivo prima non risparmia comunque nel
check point ha posto zio ti alzi 6
voglia grazie gentilissimo dove che vado
aiuto aiuto
calmati cava che zio canapi o le no non
mi fa tornare indietro
no non ci voglio che vede che ho fatto a
morire non mi ha neanche colpito mandare
a [ __ ]
buon viaggio più che tanti auguri e
figli maschi all e plasmato fa coesi voi
lo avete visto niente
ci ero riuscito in una maniera
incredibile come ho fatto a morire
veloce a dio ti ringrazio che dovevo
passato ok ciao posso fare ragazze
arrivo serio
sei amico del cemento li ho io non ci
posso fare a fare le cose base basilari
non sai fermo lo devo fare chissà cosa
niente neanche quello è il traguardo la
quindi foto illegali come lo raggiungo
basta che lo raggiungo esatto così sia
la chiave
this is a human bowling level speedster
chi deve andare veloce andiamo veloci e
finiamo livelli ho fatto fare tutto devo
fare anche questi gli specchi by quindi
non andare veloce come che mi fate
schifo rumore che sto sentendo in questo
momento che l'intero livello che
riproviamoci un'altra volta e solo
sadico il problema è questo in realtà
non lo sto facendo per qualche motivo
sono solo sadico a perché prima non
avevo vinto ma com è per me papà chi si
è incastrato nel parabrezza fantastico
back che bella scena di famiglia
regalare ai ragazzi di provare l'ultimo
che trend killer che dal nome sempre a
figo poi magari la cagata probo john e
tim per caso siamo certo si sta roba
un'altalena qui è un'altalena horror
questa fantastica che è il nostro
livello che sembra più paesaggistico
rispetto agli altri per quanto il
paesaggio faccia cagare perché la
grafica visto giocano nel massimo è però
si vede l'impegno nel non fare un
livello normale si vede l'impegno nel
tassabile palle anche o due non c'è il
pezzo di sotto come faccio a pedalare
impossibile che è che sta pedalando cosa
al pezzo di sotto ma che ora va bene
facciamoci domanda ragazzi che vivo va
bene stato preso anche il check point
ditemi voi se posso continuare così vai
frate ok sto facendo tutto livello senza
il pezzo di sotto anche perché sono
proprio perché finire livelli normali
for boys farlo senza le gambe di forme è
l'ultima che mi dà il turbo non possono
pedalare non so i piedi sai com'è
vorrei fare dei commenti ma non li
faccio in diagonale ok ma cosa nel
diagonale ha sempre funzionato regala
andare in diagonale con 26 in salita non
so perché nata però funziona mai
perfetto la fisica la fisica e la chiave
di tutto grazie a cristo gioco esiste la
fisica
beh più o meno stavo scherzando questo
amore mai rega com'è possibile
ci sono riuscito anche a rimettermi in
pista e assurdo cioè non ho le gambe sto
sopravvivendo come vabbè ci provo dai ci
provo
by stavolta credo di essere morto non ne
sono sicurissimo pro bike lei anno devo
andare di qua se sono con la bici la
scritta e non so leggere scusatemi ok lo
puoi giocare tutto perfetto
devo salire da qualche parte non una
riga non avevo visto che c'era la lane
per le bike perché magari non sono
capaci andare dritto sono un maledetto
ubriaco mamma mia mamma mia mamma mia
lega mammamia rega un [ __ ] un
[ __ ] non è possibile raga non ci
voglio cristo gioco è una tortura
porca devi sbandare una se fosse ubriaco
non sei ubriaco è questo il problema
perché non riesce ad aromi che non
riuscivo ad andare dritto mi sembrano un
mongoloide oggi che non sia arrivato al
traguardo che un serio a tutto riguardo
non morire non rifarmi tutto se voglio
rifare tutto ragazzi
ok ok le bombe magari non e tocchiamo è
ok come passo di carpino passare in
mezzo qua picchia ditelo però no l'ho
preso il turbo a picchia sono schiantati
solari però fatto di beni quanto
pensassi ragazzi va bene anche così puoi
per cortesia
fare glorioso glorioso secondo me a dir
poco frate va bè ragazzi basta che
stavolta con grazie glorie finisce qua
perché video sono tragico tragico quando
faranno altri livelli magari lo riporto
per katie hoff in chi così tutti anche
quelli fatti dal dai fan
mica assurdo però capito che siamo certi
ragazzi che quello che come senza il
momento è un bel laica anche i vari
socio economico totale descrizione ci
siete vi ci mettiamo costituito da
ragazzi
[Musica]